FEMALE SPEAKER: Hi, guys.
Thanks so much for being here
for our awesome yoga girl
Rachel Brathen today.
We're going to be having one
of her really dear friends
moderating this interview today.
Her name is Krista Lettko.
Her boat is currently docked
in the San Francisco Bay.
She runs a marketing
and production company
and she teaches yoga.
She met Rachel on
Rachel's US tour in 2013
and they did some traveling
together in Aruba.
So please welcome Krista.
[APPLAUSE]
KRISTA LETTKO: Hi.
How is everyone?
So, yoga phenomenon,
Rachel Brathen,
better known as
"yoga girl" has won
the hearts of more than one
million Instagram followers
around the world.
She shares pictures
of spectacular yoga
poses on beautiful Aruba beaches
alongside stories about life's
triumphs and heartbreaks.
Now she's bringing together
her signature wisdom
and personal journey in her
first highly anticipated book,
"Yoga Girl."
In addition to calling
Rachel my favorite yoga
instructor of all time,
I have the privilege
of calling her a dear friend.
I'm thrilled to have
her family in California
and I'm so, so grateful to be
part of the Happiness Tour.
So please welcome New York
Times' newest bestselling
author, Rachel Brathen.
[APPLAUSE]
RACHEL BRATHEN: Hey!
Hi!
Hi.
KRISTA LETTKO: Hi.
RACHEL BRATHEN: Thank
you everyone for coming.
It's like a puppy party in here.
Everybody is
attracted to Ringo, I
feel, more than anything else.
KRISTA LETTKO: So I was asked
to set up a Q&A for Rachel,
and when I read the book, I
realized a lot of the answers
are actually in the book.
Which I think is great
because so many times I
know it's a struggle
for you to connect
with every single
person that reaches out.
So we went through
your Instagram
and found the most common--
the most popular questions,
and we thought we'd
have you answer them.
RACHEL BRATHEN: That's great.
I like that.
KRISTA LETTKO: All right.
So question number one, Rachel.
When did you first start
to incorporate yoga
into your everyday life?
So when did you decide
to actually make it
something that you practiced
occasionally to being serious
every day?
RACHEL BRATHEN: It wasn't an
active choice that I made.
Yoga kind of crept
up on me sneakily.
I meet so many people that have
that "aha" moment in yoga class
where-- I took one class
and it changed my life,
and then you're a
devoted yogee forever.
For me, it was not
like that at all.
I took my first yoga class.
I couldn't touch my toes.
I couldn't do anything.
I thought I was the worst
person in the classroom.
Everybody else knew exactly
what they were doing.
And it was really a long process
of sticking with a practice
because they had a feeling
that it was helping me,
and with lots of patience
and lots of falling over
and lots of learning, it
became a part of my daily life.
KRISTA LETTKO: And
at what point did
you decide to try
Instagram, and at what
point did you say I'm going to
try out the social media thing?
I might be good at it.
RACHEL BRATHEN: I was
really obsessed with my dog
at the time.
Kind of still very
obsessed with all my dogs.
I started Instagram--
the first I ever shared
was a picture of my dog.
It wasn't a yoga-oriented thing.
I didn't have this big plan
to create a big social media
account that was going
to become a huge thing.
It was really a
personal space for me,
and I started sharing
a little bit more yoga.
And it grew slowly from there
and it became came all of this.
KRISTA LETTKO: So why do
you think your lifestyle
and philosophy on
Instagram and now
all over the world has
resonated with so many people?
What do you think about
the philosophy sticks?
RACHEL BRATHEN: The
philosophy sticks.
I try really hard to not do the
regular, general social media
thing.
Which I feel is-- it's very
much showing only our best
side of ourselves.
You can go to any person's
Instagram account,
and if it's a celebrity, or a
regular person, and everybody
is so good at everything.
And every day is
the best day ever.
Everybody is a professional
photographer and a super yogee
and a professional
chef, and you only
share these very angled and
filtered moments of your day.
No one ever shares,
you know, I'm
having the worst moment ever.
Look how boring my
life is right now.
I'm going to share
that on Instagram.
No one does that.
And it creates a very
unrealistic view of your life.
And I found the more
I get away from that
or the more I go a
little bit deeper
into the things that are real
and genuine and human, which
isn't always rainbows
and butterflies,
even though that's
very inspiring too.
But the more human
I can be online,
the more it
resonates with people
on a level that's
deeper even though it's
social media, which can be
a very superficial place.
KRISTA LETTKO: It's definitely
what resonated with me.
When I first met you,
you were in San Francisco
and you woke up that
day to teach that class
and couldn't move your back.
And she was teaching a
handstand class that night.
And it was so cool.
It was the most loving--
sweaty, but-- I don't know.
It was just the coolest
class and it was so real.
Everyone was expecting,
and you showed up in socks,
and it was just so real.
It resonated.
I know, but it was like,
oh, this is the real deal.
So that's awesome.
RACHEL BRATHEN: Yes.
Sometimes you have
to that, you know.
I wanted to teach this
advanced, inverted class.
Everybody's ready with
their Lululemon pants.
And here's this yoga girl.
Let's do it.
And I woke up in the morning
after just months of months
of stress and working
too hard, and something
snapped in my neck and
I could barely walk.
So I feel allowing that to
be there if that's the case.
It resonates way more than
handstands and all of that.
KRISTA LETTKO: So
these days most of us
have pretty busy
schedules, and I've
heard you say a couple things.
But I wanted you
to say three things
that you think
during the day people
can do to live a
more balanced, maybe
more mindful life in the midst
of the chaos that we live in.
RACHEL BRATHEN: I
very recently shared--
because I get this
question a lot,
especially from people that
are living a stressful life
or you're sitting by your
computer the whole day.
You don't move a lot.
So I actually recently shared
a big blog on office yoga,
and I had no idea it was
going to be so requested.
And everybody wants
to know, can I
do something while
sitting in my chair
while wearing the
clothes that I wear
to work to relieve the
tension that hold in my body?
And taking a moment in the
day, if it's five minutes just
to kind of turnaround and
away from your computer.
Turn your phone off and
just breathe and feel.
You know, what does
it feel like to sit?
Am I sitting like this the
whole day with my neck like this
and my shoulders like this?
Can I do something
with my posture.
Can I invite a little bit more
body awareness into the moment
and maybe change subtle
things to make me feel better.
So five minutes in
the day, you can
do a little bit of stretching.
Maybe just a twist
in your chair.
Like how are you guys
feeling right now?
Are you comfortable
on your mats?
Want to do a little
twist to kind of wake up?
KRISTA LETTKO: I
think we should.
RACHEL BRATHEN: OK.
So just sit up tall.
Whatever you're doing with
your legs is totally OK.
And just take a little twist
over towards the right.
So you bring one
hand on your knee,
the other one on the ground
behind the lower back.
You can do this in
your office chair
as well just holding on
to the edge of the chair.
And then lifting up to the crown
of the head and just lightly
gaze over the shoulder.
Welcome.
Then we take a deep breath
in and a deep breath out.
And then gently come
back to center and just
to the exact same thing
on the other side.
So one hand behind you,
the other one underneath.
Take a breath in to
lengthen and lift up
as if you're growing taller.
And as you exhale,
twisting over to the left.
And a big breath
in and breath out.
Good, and then come
back to center.
How do we feel?
A little bit of energy.
KRISTA LETTKO: There's
a difference though.
RACHEL BRATHEN: There
is a difference.
It can be very
subtle, but when we
sit all day or stand
all day, that energy
tends to get very
stuck in the spine.
So just something as simple
as a twist in your chair can
really-- it's like a
little shot of espresso
without the caffeine.
And you wanted two
more things, you said?
KRISTA LETTKO: Yes.
Three things throughout the day.
RACHEL BRATHEN: Someone
asked me this recently
and I was like in
my office, which
is at home and not at Google.
I don't know if they
would ever allow this,
but I like to make my work
space very appealing to me.
And for me, that always involves
lighting a little candle.
And someone was
interviewing me, and they're
like I don't think we can have
open fire in our office space.
I was like, oh, well.
Maybe a little vase of flowers
or a photo of someone you love.
Or bring your dog to work if
you're allowed to do that.
Something that creates
a smile on your face.
And deep breaths
all day, everyday,
would be my number three.
KRISTA LETTKO: OK,
so next question
is I know when different
phases bring you
up and down through
your yoga practice.
Sometimes you're more gentle.
Other times it's really sweaty.
What's your yoga
practice like right
now, especially
with the traveling?
How's that going?
RACHEL BRATHEN: It's going
better than last year.
I really made an effort-- I'm
on the road for two months,
and I realize if I don't
actually schedule time
for the yoga practice or to
meditate or even schedule time
to take my dog to the
park, these things
become de-prioritized by
meetings and more important
things that happened
in your work day.
So it's working out pretty well.
I have actually reached out to
teachers in different cities
where we go and I have-- some
days it's just me and my mat.
Some days we'll have a
teacher come to my hotel room
in this tiny little corner.
You kind of take
what you can get.
KRISTA LETTKO: OK,
so the next question
is what it is one of the
most unusual places you've
had the opportunity
to teach recently?
RACHEL BRATHEN: The
most unusual plays
that I teach these days
is at home where I live.
Which it's always
exciting to be home.
It happens very
rarely, but I find
it's more about that
the people that I meet
or the people that
come to class.
We were in Brielle, New
Jersey, which I had never
heard of in my life.
We were in Connecticut and
these small little places,
and the love and the wisdom
and just authenticity
that came from these people
in these small towns.
It's not exotic.
It's not like Brazil or Costa
Rica or Aruba where I live,
but it was just really an exotic
experience going to that town
and seeing these
people-- in a small town
and these people that
practice yoga every day.
They're not the
people that we maybe
follow on Instagram or
the people that we see.
It was really a
nice change for me.
It was really-- I'm really
excited about this tour
and meeting people in
more unusual places.
KRISTA LETTKO: So speaking
of the tour, congratulations.
We got some good news
yesterday about the book.
RACHEL BRATHEN: Yay!
KRISTA LETTKO: Very exciting.
How's the tour going?
How's it been going?
This is a whirlwind.
How long are you traveling for?
RACHEL BRATHEN: Two months.
KRISTA LETTKO: Two months.
And is it just the
US, or what's--
RACHEL BRATHEN: It's all across
the US, and we have Vancouver.
So kind of Canada a little bit.
But it's going
really well so far.
It's been really busy.
I'm so happy to be in San
Francisco or the West Coast
where there is sunshine.
It was snowing in New
York when we were there
two days ago, which is not
a happy place for me at all.
But so far, it's
really, really nice.
KRISTA LETTKO: So
what's been the biggest
surprise in this whole process
so far writing your first book?
Now going out on
your first tour?
What's the biggest-- I
guess the most unexpected--
the biggest thing
that's happened so far?
Maybe aside from--
RACHEL BRATHEN: Aside from
the New York Times bestseller
thing.
I found throughout
this tour-- this
is the first time since I
have this the social media
following and everyday people
reaching out and writing
and commenting and emailing.
And I always-- when I
travel, I only teach classes.
So it's just come take a yoga
class, come to a workshop,
bring your yoga mat.
And I realize now that I'm
doing more book signings
or other events and meetups.
How many people that are
in this community that are
so terrified of yoga practice?
So they wanted to come
and they want to connect,
but they're not ready to
step on the mat just yet.
KRISTA LETTKO: Interesting.
RACHEL BRATHEN: It's
really interesting,
and I used to think
that, oh, "yoga girl."
It's like a yoga
specific community.
It's not.
It's really a heart
specific community.
And it's people that,
you know, they're
not ready for their
first down dog yet.
They're intrigued.
They want to buy the book.
They want to say hi.
They want to hug.
They want to meet my
dog and my husband,
but it's not about
the yoga as much
as I originally have thought.
It's really to me more
about sparking something
in people that inspires them
with whatever they have.
It doesn't have to be
the other practice.
It could be whatever is their
passions or their dreams.
KRISTA LETTKO: Wow,
that's so great.
I didn't think that was going
to be-- that's really great.
So this is your first book.
Hopefully not your last.
What was the biggest
challenge in writing the book
in this process?
What was the hardest part?
RACHEL BRATHEN: The
hardest part-- well,
when I start writing, I
have a hard time stopping.
For this book, I wanted it to
be almost like my Instagram
account, but in a book form.
It's very lively and
full of pretty pictures,
and there's recipes in
there and yoga sequences.
And then my own story
has the depth of that.
But I have another book
in me that is maybe not
as sparkly and
shiny as this book,
and when I start going
into personal experiences,
sometimes I go really,
really, really deep.
And even when I brought
this book to the-- because
I wrote it in Sweden first
and brought it to the States.
And I had to have things cleared
with lawyers at the publishing
house.
Like are you allowed
to write these things?
Is that OK?
Can they sue you?
And I'm like, I don't know.
In Sweden, we don't
sue each other
for writing about what
happened in your life.
So it's been a balance of
sharing the true me-- a deeper
version of my life, and
keeping it very accessible
and motivating.
KRISTA LETTKO: That's so funny.
Did you write it in
Swedish and English first?
RACHEL BRATHEN: English.
But for a Swedish
publisher, and I
had to translate my
own book into Swedish
because I write
better in English
than I do in Swedish now.
And then for the
American version,
we actually extended it.
I wrote a lot more, so then
I had to rewrite again.
So I kind of wrote three
books this past year.
It's been a big process.
Making a book is
not just writing it
and handing something
in and then you're done.
It would be nice if that
was the case, but it's not.
KRISTA LETTKO: So you told
me the biggest challenge now.
I'd like to know-- this is
actually my last question,
then we'll open it up.
It's what was your
favorite part to write?
What's your favorite part
of the book, or maybe
your favorite page
or quote or picture?
What's your favorite
thing about the book?
RACHEL BRATHEN: I really
love the last chapter.
Every chapter
corresponds or correlates
to a part of yoga practice.
I have a chapter on back bends.
I have a chapter on arm balances
and inversions and all of that.
And the last chapter is about
meditation and finding silence.
Which I find that is
the most important part
of the yoga practice.
Which people-- it's harder
to get to because it's
a little bit more daunting.
Sitting down with yourself in
silence with no distractions
can be a terrifying thing.
But it's also what I
find creates the most
change in a person's life.
More than sweating
on the yoga mat
or doing a handstand or
a downward facing dog,
and I really love that.
I love to inspire that
part of the practice team.
Being with yourself and finding
those moments of silence
in your life.
KRISTA LETTKO:
Yeah, it's awesome.
Cool.
I love the book.
RACHEL BRATHEN: Thank you.
KRISTA LETTKO: I read
it in one sitting.
It's so good.
So thank you so much.
Thank you for being here.
Congratulations.
RACHEL BRATHEN: Thank you.
KRISTA LETTKO: And
I'd like to open it up
if there's anybody that had
some questions that they
want ask Rachel directly.
Catherine's walking
around with a mic.
Don't be shy, we're all--
RACHEL BRATHEN: It could
be a dog related question
if you want.
It doesn't have to be yoga.
It could be anything.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question actually.
OK, if you were to pick three
poses to do in the morning,
like quickly before work.
That's my biggest struggle
is I want to get to work,
but I really want to open up
and not-- when you wake up,
you're like all stiff.
So what are three
poses you would
say after waking up in the
morning to just kind of flow
through?
RACHEL BRATHEN: Yeah.
You can even do-- just
the moment you wake up,
I like to stay in bed and kind
of use the surface you're on.
Just to create some
movement for the spine.
So the spine moves
in so many ways.
Well, we just did now a twist.
You can do that same thing
lying down on your back.
Kind of wish I was in
yoga pants right now.
I'm not.
Do you want to demonstrate?
KRISTA LETTKO: Sure.
Yes, I knew that was coming.
RACHEL BRATHEN: Of course.
So lying on your back, bringing
one knee into your chest.
And then just gently drawing
that towards one side,
so just taking that
over to the left.
KRISTA LETTKO: My
mic is on my back.
RACHEL BRATHEN: That's OK.
So something as simple as this.
And then come back to center
and do the other side.
You can do that on any surface.
You're creating some
movement, and again,
that energy that gets lodged in
the spine helps to wake us up.
And then for me--
it's not for everyone.
Back of the legs tend
to get very tight.
You can bring one
leg up to the sky
and bring it closer
into the body.
Just lying in your
bed or your yoga mat
in your kitchen wherever
you are, and just do
both legs like that.
Creating some
space for the back.
And then come sitting up.
And I'll do this along with you.
So just bringing
your hands behind you
with the wrist pointing
towards your sits bones.
It's taking a moment
to open the chest.
Just like this.
Just lifting through the heart.
You guys can all do
this with me right now.
KRISTA LETTKO: Wrists
facing towards me?
RACHEL BRATHEN: No, your
wrists facing the sits bones,
and then lifting your heart,
shoulders back, drop your head.
Just start to open and
expand through the heart
and the chest.
So it's not an intense pose.
Just a little bit
of spaciousness.
And then coming back up.
Slight little yoga moment.
Yeah, so anything
that feels good.
We all have our homework
when it comes to our bodies.
For me it's-- my shoulders
are always my number one tight
spot.
If you have your hips or the
back of your legs or your neck,
finding a pose that alleviates
that that you can do every day.
That's what you need to work
on in your own practice.
AUDIENCE: I'd loved to hear your
experience or thoughts coming
to a place like
Google, and I don't
know if you've been to other
places in Silicon Valley.
But I kind of find that we're in
a little bit of a bubble here.
Like it's such a different
world than-- I'm sure
Aruba or anywhere else
in the United States.
So I'm just curious
what your experience
is coming in to these
buildings and these offices.
RACHEL BRATHEN: This
place is amazing.
I just had lunch
in the cafeteria,
and I was just blown away.
I wish I get to eat
this every single day.
I feel this is a special place.
But just coming into
any work environment
where people are working this
closely together all the time
and you're really, really
busy throughout your day.
I feel like there's so much
potential and opportunity
to create more of
that connection
beyond just the working
together and doing your tasks
and everything you need
to do with its-- I mean,
having yoga sessions or
moments of mindfulness classes.
I find all of that just
helps to improve how well we
perform in our work days.
It's not so much about grinding
our way through everything
we have to do in the
day, but actually
stepping away sometimes
and setting some time
for you will make you
feel better at work too.
And it's fun, and
it can actually
expand into the rest of
the areas of your life.
AUDIENCE: What do
you think-- kind
of a familiar question
like the three--
it doesn't have to be three,
but kind of your biggest lessons
learned from turning into
this social media celebrity.
It seems kind of unplanned.
That's what I'm thinking of.
I know when your best
friend passed away
and you were being really real.
And I saw some posting
like, hey, this is me.
I'm not going to be doing--
I'm not perfect every day.
I'm not happy every day.
I'm actually going to be
posting some sad stuff.
If you're not OK with it,
you don't have to follow me.
But I'm just curious.
Like what kind of
things have you learned
about the world or
people in general
and how to interact
based on your experience?
RACHEL BRATHEN: I learned
a lot and it keeps coming.
Those crazy social
media lessons.
I feel social media can be an
absolutely terrifying place.
Like any platform can be
a narcissistic place where
your ego gets this space to
be look at me, look at me,
like me, follow me, and
it's so easy just to tell.
You can have that feeling of
checking out someone's account
and feeling like, oh, is this
either inspiring and motivating
or does it inspire jealousy or
inspired me to feel inadequate
or like I need to
change who I am?
So I feel what you give out
is what you get in return.
And there's so many-- I
sometimes go to other people,
like celebrities or people
that have a big, big platforms
and just scroll through
the comments feeds.
And it's scary sometimes
what people write and tell
each other.
Things they would never
in a million years
say to someone's face ever.
That's like hiding
behind your phone
creates this monster of blurting
out the most obnoxious things.
But it also comes from
what you share, and I
find every single time that
I reach a little bit deeper
and I share something
that maybe isn't easy.
I mean, it's not something
beautiful or a beautiful meal
I cooked or a yoga pose.
It's like something real that
took effort for me to share.
I get all of that
love in return.
Like all of it.
There's a whole
gazillion amounts
of people out there with wisdom
would love that positivity that
connect and care.
And that can also be brought
out through social media.
You just have to decide
to take that road.
And I can really tell--
so it's really everyday.
Whatever I share I can really
guide it really easily.
Do I want the following
to take this turn today?
It's so easy to create drama
if that's what you want.
But I feel we get so much
drama thrown at us every day.
We don't need to
create more of it.
And it's also a nice lesson.
I like to-- when my friend
passed away, for instance,
so many people started sharing
their own moments of grief.
They never before--
someone passed away
or they lost someone, and
you put on this big smile
afterwards.
I'm fine, I'm fine.
And you're not.
So every time you're
genuine to who you are
and you share that, it allows
other people to be true to what
they're feeling as well.
It's like a little
ripple effect of truth
as opposed to a ripple
effect of oh, my God,
what did Justin Bieber
drink last night?
All these crazy things that
happened in social media
that in the big scheme of
things don't mean a whole lot.
AUDIENCE: So as
you've gotten older
and moved through
different life phases,
how have you seen
your practice evolve
and how do you see
it evolving as you
move into other life phases?
RACHEL BRATHEN: I really find
that the yoga practice does
change as your life changes,
and it really moves as a tide.
It peaks, and it
goes down, and it's
learning how to adapt to
that flow really helps.
I used to have this idea
that my yoga practice has
to be 90 minutes in a class.
And yes, I'm doing
Chaturanga, sweating,
or it didn't really
feel like yoga.
That was at the beginning
of my first year,
so I was really getting
into the practice.
And then my life started
changing and I'm travelling all
the time.
I don't have time anymore.
I'm not in the studio space.
I'm not teaching
classes everyday.
I have hotel rooms and airports.
There's not a lot of space for
90 minutes of vinyasa, then.
And then, what I need
is a gentler practice.
When everything is
spinning really quickly,
then that needs to be
a place of silence.
Of restorative yoga
slowing down and yin.
Some days my practice
is five minutes
of me putting my legs up
the wall, and that's great.
It won't be like that every day,
but just allowing the practice
to move as your life
moves is really valuable.
And I know it will go back up
again, and then go back down
and then go back up.
AUDIENCE: So I do
some of the practices
that you posted online,
like the Gaiam ones,
and I really, really love them.
And my favourite quote that
you say is something like,
I think we're in pigeon, and
you say if you want to release
a little bit more, now
is always a good time.
And I find that idea is kind
of so inspirational to me
that I could just-- now is the
time to make changes in my life
and things like that.
But I also find that
there's a part of me that's
like you have to be
realistic about having a job
and having a house
and all these things.
So how do you kind
of balance the
want to make big
changes with the need
to be realistic about
what's happening?
KRISTA LETTKO: That's
a good question.
RACHEL BRATHEN: That's
a great question.
I mean, now is always
a really good time.
And if you're constantly
waiting for your life
to be perfect, to
invite change--
if that's what you want--
it's never going to happen.
I mean, it's really easy
to say, OK, on January 1,
I'm going to change my life.
New beginning.
Or next Monday I'm
going to start,
or when I'm not this busy.
Or only when my kids grow older.
Or when this and this and this
and this and that happens.
And then in the end,
time passes and we end up
being stuck in the
same place we wanted
to get out of years earlier.
I really believe in this
change that we want to create.
It needs to come from a really
genuine place of lovingly
wanting to change something.
And I find it's such
a big difference
of-- people ask me a lot.
OK, can I-- I want
to lose weight.
I need to lose weight.
Can yoga help me lose weight?
Yoga can help you lose weight.
I mean, there's lots
of things you can do.
But why do you want
to lose weight?
That's, I think, the
more important question.
You want to lose
weight because you
look at yourself in
the mirror and you
feel like I'm not good enough.
This is not good.
What I have right
now is not enough.
I am not good enough.
I need to change.
Changing from that place, of not
loving who you are, is so hard.
Which is why there's a gazillion
diets out there and people
crash diet, and then
you gain the weight back
AND then you go back down.
And then in the end, even
if you lose that weight,
you're still going to
want to do something else.
You're not going to find that
place of true contentment.
I lost 10 pounds,
now I love who I am.
You know, it doesn't
work that way.
We think that's how it is.
If I'm a supermodel,
I will love who I am.
No.
Either love who you
are or you don't.
And I think finding that
love first and realizing
how important that is.
And, OK, this is who I am.
This is the body
I am blessed with.
Maybe I have aches and pains.
Maybe I'm big or I'm small,
I'm old or I'm young, whatever.
But this is me and I can choose
to own and love and accept
and embrace that these are
the cards I'm dealt with.
And I fucking rock.
And then from there, if I
want to lose weight, OK.
It's way easier
because I know it's
going to make me feel better.
I'm going to be healthier.
I'll live longer.
I can run faster.
I can play with my kids more.
I can do this and that.
And that change is so
much easier to access.
And then that moment
of now is going
to be so much
easier to find too.
No, it's a really good question.
And I feel like the yoga
practicing-- there are so
many ways to get there.
But coming back to the
heart over and over again
is the most important thing.
And if you do that through
meditation or through yoga
or through running or
through playing with your dog
or whatever it is
that brings you back
to a moment of heartfulness.
That's where it's at.
It really is.
KRISTA LETTKO: I think, too,
one of my favorite Rachel--
I don't know what I call
them-- Rachel lessons that
relates to making those
pivotal decisions.
As you said to me, you either
choose love or you choose fear.
And if it scares you,
then you have to do it.
But it's going back
to this idea is
why are you making a decision.
And if it's scaring you, is
that what's holding you back?
Or is it what?
Coming at it with
this loving thing.
And it totally just
shifted every decision
I've made since then.
And it really-- can I trace it
back to is this something I'm
doing out of fear?
Like, oh, I'm worried
this isn't going to happen
or real, genuine,
authentic love.
I love that.
RACHEL BRATHEN: Cool.
KRISTA LETTKO: Thank you.
RACHEL BRATHEN: Thank you.
Yeah, there's a whole
chapter on that in the book.
KRISTA LETTKO: Yes, there is.
RACHEL BRATHEN: And
it's not always easy,
but we do our best.
thank you so much.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I think
we're going to wrap it up,
and Rachel's going to be doing a
book signing just right outside
once I give her her shoes back.
So if you guys just want to
form a line outside and thank
you so much for being here.
That was awesome.
RACHEL BRATHEN:
Thanks, everyone.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]